Ring Ring Ring Ring Ring!
Banana Phone!
Haha, classic.
We like to have fun over here at SCP explained,
and that’s why today we’ll be talking
about one of the more sweet and playful anomalies
that the Foundation has in containment.
If by “sweet” we mean it smells like overripe
fruit and by “playful” we mean carnivorous
and genetically unstable, then yes, that’s
exactly what’s in store for us.
Meet SCP-2761 - a mutant hybrid we’ve affectionately
nicknamed Banana-Zilla due the SCP’s retractable
frill, which resembles the peel of a banana
tree fruit.
Though, at first glance, this part of SCP-2761’s
anomalous anatomy might appear fanciful, like
something out of a cartoon or children’s
picture book, Bananazilla is no laughing matter,
and it boasts far fewer novel surprises across
the length of its twelve-meter body.
The fact is, SCP-2761 could prove an existential
threat to every natural ecosystem on earth
if it were ever to escape containment.
The reason for this happens to be SCP-2761’s
infinitely adaptable genetic code which seems
to constantly evolve in response to its consumption
of other organisms.
At present, SCP-2761 is amphibious and can
thrive as easily in salt water as it does
in the freshwater of its containment unit
at Site-71.
While it does possess gills, they are extremely
small, similar in proportion to those found
on species in the pipefish subfamily.
The Foundation’s research into the creature’s
origin has led to the prevailing theory that
it may have begun its life as an ordinary
pipefish subject to DNA-splicing at a retail
company known as Aquagene - which specializes
in the sale of genetically modified aquatic
pets.
Regardless of its origin, SCP-2761 shares
genotypic and phenotypic traits with over
five dozen species of flora and fauna aside
from pipefish.
The majority of these species belong to the
animal kingdom and overwhelmingly tend to
belong to the amphibian, ray-finned fish,
or reptile classes.
These borrowed genes express themselves in
a variety of ways, but always in a manner
that seems beneficial to SCP-2761.
Bananazilla’s gigantic body is capable of
explosive bursts at speed, much like soft-shelled
turtles, which, over the course of their natural
evolution, sacrificed more protective armor
to gain greater mobility.
For the purpose of detecting prey, Bananazilla
has sixteen barbels - more commonly referred
to as catfish whiskers - which, like its frill,
are fully retractable.
In terms of physical appearance, SCP-2761
has many traits in common with American alligators.
This includes the over one hundred undifferentiated
conical teeth which SCP-2761 can use to devour
live prey.
There are nearly sixty additional rows of
teeth within SCP-2671’s mouth which, on
the off chance that the hybrid loses any teeth
in the front row, will naturally move forward
to replace them.
The process by which SCP-2671 regenerates
lost teeth is nearly identical to that of
a bull shark, however, the replacement teeth
vary in shape and apparent utility.
Some rows of bananazilla’s backup teeth
are uniformly serrated and evenly spaced while
other rows are villiform with prominent, elongated
canines like that of a yellowtail snapper
fish.
A dental examination of SCP-2761 revealed
that towards the back of its mouth, there
were even rows of teeth that bore an uncanny
resemblance to those found within a species
of great ape: the human species, to be exact.
The alligator-like claws at the end SPC-2761’s
powerful, compact limbs have sticky pads on
the underside which have enough adhesive strength
to allow SCP-2761 to climb into trees and
across other uneven surfaces: such as the
artificial rock wall we’ve provided bananazilla
in its containment unit for the purpose of
exercise and stimulation.
These adhesive pads are identical to the ones
found on the toes of green anole lizards,
which SCP-2761 appears to have inherited other
characteristics from - such as the ability
to perceive ultraviolet light and limited
color changing for the purpose of camouflage.
When SCP-2761 was first discovered deep in
the heart of the Florida Everglades, the range
of its color-changing ability comprised several
shades of green and brown - from a vibrant,
lustrous green like that of an emerald gemstone
to a dark muddy hue that made it nearly invisible
in murky water.
It is believed that the consistent diet of
banana fruit that The Foundation provides
to SCP-2761 has been able to gradually offset
its camouflage capabilities, inadvertently
causing it to retain the natural coloration
of bright yellow that it has become known
for.
The secret to SCP-2761’s vast amount of
genetic information lies in its cellular structure.
Each cell in SCP-2761’s bulky body has an
abnormally large nucleus with a primary genome
made up of hundreds of distinct genes.
There are additional genomes stored separately
within the nuclei as well, which have been
heavily scrutinized by research personnel
of Level 3 and above.
All available data seems to suggest that SCP-2671’s
full genetic code contains the completely
unaltered genomes of every species it has
ever eaten.
This includes a diverse microbiome of bacteria
and organic compounds which would be hazardous
to most other creatures but seem to only affect
the hybrid carnivore’s health in terms of
conferring benefits.
Though the various diseases and genetic disorders
that SCP-2761 harbors within its body present
no safety risk to the SCP itself, any blood-borne
or contagious strains of microscopic life
are still more than capable of having their
usual adverse effects on other species.
To prevent the spread of these harmful pathogens,
The Foundation has lined the containment unit
for SCP-2761 with lead - as the heavy metal
is known to induce anti-microbial activity.
Despite the tendency for SCP-2761 to undergo
rapid mutation within its primary genome,
the numerous unaltered genomes within its
cells have never shown signs of independent
mutation.
Instead, the unaltered genomes serve a function
that is metaphorically comparable to the extra
rows of teeth within SCP-2761’s mouth.
Whenever the primary genome suffers damage
or makes contact with potentially hazardous
new stimuli, genetic information is transferred
from the unaltered genomes to repair SCP-2761’s
genetic expression and, in the process, cause
further beneficial mutations to take place.
In short, SCP-2761 is capable of storing unexpressed
genetic data within its cells, which then
become apparent in its physical characteristics,
provided that those changes make it fitter
to survive in its current environment.
The untapped potential of this advanced form
of genetic rearrangement has become increasingly
enticing to The Foundation.
Not unlike the enticing taste of a fresh,
delicious banana.
As the saying goes, SCP-2761 is what it eats.
Therefore, it stands to reason that altering
the hybrid’s food intake could, over time,
lead to a genetic expression that would therein
prove useful to The Foundation’s goals.
This is especially true when the mutable properties
of SCP-2761 are compared to those of a similar
but far more dangerous reptilian SCP - the
infamous SCP-682.
While SCP-682 is nearly impossible to destroy
due to its instantaneous adaptation, the changes
to its physiology recede and disappear when
no longer required to ensure its survival.
SCP-2761, on the other hand, retains the sum
total of every useful feature it has gleaned
from its diet.
Presently, SCP-2761 possesses barely a fraction
of SCP-682’s overall strength and destructive
capability, but if raised properly within
a long enough time frame, with a steady and
balanced diet of the optimal anomalous and
non-anomalous organisms, it is theorized that
SCP-2761 could molded into the ideal countermeasure
for its reptilian rival.
And most crucially to the plan, because Bananazilla
hunts only out of the carnivorous instinct
for sustenance and survival, it lacks any
of the malice towards other life which defines
the twisted Joker-like psychology of the hard-to-destroy
reptile.
If this desirable outcome were somehow to
be achieved, the final containment of SCP-682
would be all but assured - even if its total
and permanent destruction remained forever
out of The Foundation’s reach.
For now, even the notion of broadening SCP-2671’s
diet has been deemed to be far too risky to
attempt.
Even a mouth-watering jumbo-sized bucket of
seemingly harmless non-specific restaurant
brand chicken wings could cause the hybrid
to develop razor-sharp talons, a highly-disturbing
morning call, or an unforeseen boost in intelligence
that might aid it in escaping containment.
Not to mention the possible spread of avian
influenza.
Though the finer details regarding Bananazilla’s
genetics are known only to sufficiently high-ranking
members of the genetic research team, rumors
have circulated throughout site-71 that this
humble SCP may still prove to be an incredible
asset in another way if the highly adaptable
cells within its body can somehow be replicated.
This has recently been the obsession of one
Dr. Scapelli, who as an avid reader of comic
books and manga, has hypothesized - or more
accurately fantasized - that the human genome
could be augmented through the integration
of transplanted cells from SCP-2761.
In Scapelli’s eyes, which by all estimates
are filled with a naive optimism generally
unexpected in a Level 3 researcher, a successful
transplant could turn a regular human being
into a highly-adaptable mutant super being:
able to become stronger with every meal.
Amidst the persistent worry of his scientific
peers, Dr. Scapelli has, in his off-duty hours,
drafted unofficial plans for what he believes
could be the greatest mobile task force The
Foundation has ever known.
These heroic warriors would be given the designation
Mobile Task Force Tau-68, but all the villains
in the world would know and fear them by their
clever and ingenious code name:
The Banana Splits!
While every recipient of a successful bananazilla
cell transplant would be allowed into the
group, a core team of specialists would be
chosen to embody Dr. Scapelli’s wildly imaginative
and yet incredibly specific tastes.
Standing at the top of the food chain would
be the task force’s chief commander: Apex
Man!
With an all-meat diet consisting of the most
deadly predators from around the globe, Apex
Man would “bear” the responsibilities
of leadership, “badger” the bad guys,
“wolf” down all “snakes in the grass”,
and “crocodile rock” the world into everlasting
peace with his “eagle”-litarian ways,
and he’s not “lion”.
Okay, we’ll stop…
For now.
Apex Man’s loyal second-in-command would
be Honey Girl, empowered by the environmental
DNA of thousands of pollinated plants and
the bees that tend to them.
This graceful soldier of justice would have
The Foundation’s enemies sneezing for mercy
with her countless allergenic attacks.
Flower power, indeed!
Next, of course, would be The Lord of Sea
- a pescatarian who’s always part shellfish
but never a bit selfish when it comes to saving
the day!
His powerful retractable tentacles would squeeze
the fight out of even the most wicked villain,
and with shark-like teeth of his own: he’d
never fail to take a bite out of anomalous
crime.
Watching over the team from the skies is Wild
Turkey!
Gobbling up important reconnaissance data
as quickly as he gobbles up his favorite poultry
dishes, this bad birdman is here to give evildoers
a “fowl” time.
Last but not least would be the teen tofu
titan himself: The Cube.
One hundred percent boy.
One hundred percent soy.
Dr. Scapelli’s eventual proposal for Mobile
Task Force Tau-68 was met with uproarious
laughter and was unanimously turned down by
every Level 3 and higher personnel who was
present to hear it.
O5-1 actually gave him ten bucks afterwards,
as thanks for giving him such a good giggle.
Dr. Scapelli was not pleased.
Disgraced and humiliated, Dr. Scapelli chose
to take a lengthy sabbatical from Site-71.
But as he packed up his notes for Mobile Task
Force Tau-68 - which included several pencil
and paper illustrations he had done by hand
- the researcher was overcome with a sense
of righteous purpose.
The Banana Splits were an idea so brilliant
that he just couldn’t give up on them.
If the Foundation wouldn’t help Dr. Scapelli
realize his dream, he had an idea who would.
On the night before he departed from Site-71,
Scapelli used his authority as a member of
Level 3 personnel to access the research lab
and secure a DNA sample from SCP-2761.
He proceeded to erase any and all records
of him having entered the lab that night.
Without any further delay, Dr. Scapelli booked
a nonstop flight to the sunshine state of
Florida.
He had one destination in mind: the Orlando
regional headquarters of Aquagene.
Surely, the company responsible for accidentally
creating bananazilla would understand the
importance of using their genetic research
for the betterment of the world.
Yes, of course, they would understand, Scapelli
thought to himself as he fell asleep on the
plane.
While he napped, Dr. Scapelli dreamed of the
glorious day that his secret Mobile Task Force
would save the world and prove everyone who
ever doubted him to be totally in the wrong.
In the dream, several dangerous SCPs had escaped
containment, including SCP-058: The Heart
of Darkness.
The Keter-class monstrosity was on a brutal
rampage throughout its containment facility,
lashing out with its horrifying tendrils at
any personnel within reach.
Just when all hope seemed lost, Dr. Scapelli
would arrive with Mobile Task Force Tau-68
in tow.
All of the coolest and strongest members of
the super team were standing at his side,
ready for action: Apex Man, Honey Girl, The
Lord of Sea, Wild Turkey, and The Cube.
“Banana Splits, Assemble!”
Dr. Scapelli’s dream self shouted.
His genetically-modified heroes proceeded
to bring the ultimate smackdown to SCP-058.
From the palms of her hands, Honey Girl unleashed
viscous globs of her namesake substance which
stuck The Heart of Darkness’ arthropod legs
to the floor: holding it in place.
As expected, the heart began to launch into
one of its unnerving speeches thought to drive
listeners to madness, but Wild Turkey made
gobbling noises at the top of his lungs to
drown out the sound.
Trapped and effectively silenced but not defeated,
SCP-058’s thrashing tentacles were still
a major problem - until The Lord of The Sea
extended his own tentacles to match the monster
blow for blow.
Finally, Apex Man’s grizzly bear DNA could
no longer resist the honey-covered heart in
front of him, and he closed in on SCP-058
to crush it with the granddaddy of bear hugs
before scarfing it down with a noisy crunch.
The Heart of Darkness was beaten and eaten
in that order.
The other researchers cheered and clapped
for Dr. Scapelli and for his Banana Splits.
Overcome with unconditional praise the likes
of which Dr. Scapelli had never experienced,
everyone around him began to chant his name:
“Scapelli!
Scapelli!
Scapelli!”
The dream version of Apex Man approached Dr.
Scapelli and gave his creator a congratulatory
pat on the back.
“Those who hide unwanted things in the fog
must eternally reckon with the afterimage
of his twilight’s sinful longing,” said
Apex Man in the vocal tone and accent of an
elderly British man.
He proceeded to sprout four tentacles similar
to those of SCP-058.
Dr. Scapelli jolted awake with a scream, only
to see that he was the last one still aboard
his plane.
An irritated flight attendant told the researcher
that the flight had touched down at Orlando
National Airport, and that he needed to grab
his carry-on luggage and exit the aircraft
immediately.
Scapelli didn’t need to be told twice.
He made a beeline out of the airport and called
a cab to take him to the resort he had booked
for his stay.
After settling into a hotel room, the researcher
made a few phone calls, and before long, he
was able to secure an impromptu meeting with
two of the scientists in Aquagene’s employ:
Dr. Pearl Watkins and Dr. Marcus Nakamura.
Both Watkins and Nakamura had been previously
contacted by Foundation researcher Mathew
Liu, under the guise of a meeting with the
EPA.
The Foundation had been keeping tabs on them
since then while maintaining their cover.
While the scientists had assisted in the successful
containment of SCP-2761, the potential of
Aquagene’s genetic technology needed to
be monitored in the event of further anomalous
creations.
It wasn’t difficult for Dr. Scapelli to
insert himself into the narrative that Aquagene
already believed: posing as another agent
of the EPA looking to inspect the company’s
policies.
Of course, since he was operating without
the permission of the Foundation, Dr. Scapelli
made sure that the meeting was held at Aquagene
Headquarters.
Watkins and Nakamura were apprehensive enough,
given the scrutiny that researcher Liu had
put them under in their first meeting, and
became increasingly alarmed as Dr. Scapelli
presented them with the SCP-2761 sample as
well as his “creative” pitch.
“It would be a superhero group!
Like in the movies!”
Dr. Scapelli exclaimed, having just spoken
at length about the viability of Mobile Task
Force Tau-68.
The Aquagene employees exchanged terror-stricken
looks.
Nakamura was the first to speak:
“It is a tempting offer…”
Marcus begun, trying to be polite “...but
our budget is stretched thin enough as it
is.
Your project…”
He jumped with shock as Dr. Scapelli cut him
off mid sentence:
“Don’t worry about the funding!
I can cover it out of pocket.
Sure, I may have to take out a loan and possibly
apply for unemployment, but isn't saving the
world worth any price?”
Watkins responded: “We try to do things
very carefully here, Agent Scapelli.
I’ll be blunt, what you’re describing
is far beyond the scope of our research, and
using live human test subjects for this seems
highly unethical.”
“Unethical?”
Dr. Scapelli said, baffled.
“What could possibly be unethical about
giving people to fight evil?”
“I think what Pearl is trying to say is…”
Nakura chimed in.
“...this all seems a bit naive.”
Dr. Scapelli sunk into his chair, feeling
defeated.
First, the Foundation had rejected his idea,
and now Aquagene too.
Perhaps it really was time to give up on Mobile
Task Force Tau-68.
If he pressed his luck any further at Aquagene,
word could get back to Site-71, and he’d
have to kiss his career at The Foundation
goodbye - and potentially his memories, if
they decided to give him a hefty dose of Amnestics
as part of his severance package.
Later that night in the resort restaurant,
Dr. Scapelli was crying into his plate of
food.
His dreams of creating the world’s first
superhero team had been crushed that day,
and he still had the rest of his sabbatical
to spend in Florida.
As he tried to eat his steak, he was reminded
of Apex Man and broke down into tears all
over again.
The other restaurant patrons were beginning
to stare at Dr. Scapelli, and he was about
to consider leaving when a man in dark shades
approached his table and sat down across from
him.
The man waited for Scapelli to cease his weeping
before formally introducing himself as Dr.
Gregory Higgins.
He claimed to be a former employee of Aquagene,
and had used insider information from an old
colleague to learn about Dr. Scapelli’s
meeting with Watkins and Nakamura.
By tracing the call from the resort earlier
that afternoon, it wasn’t that difficult
to track the Foundation researcher down.
“Are you going to call me naive too?”
Scapelli said in a huff.
“Far from it,” Higgins replied, wearing
a mischievous grin.
“I think your idea has potential.”
“You really mean it?”
Scapelli’s face lit up.
Higgins laughed.
“Of course.
But then again… what do I know?
I’m just the guy who created that Bananazilla!”
He continued: “…It was a complete accident,
of course, but I think we could really make
Pearl and Marcus regret ever doubting us if
this superhero thing goes the way you think
it will.”
Dr. Scapelli smiled.
“Higgins, this is the beginning of a beautiful
partnership.”
The two genetic scientists - one formerly
of the Foundation and the other formerly of
Aquagene - laughed in shared joy at the things
they might soon accomplish.
There were only two words to describe the
chaos that might ensue from the combined imagination
of this couple of mad geniuses: totally bananas!
Now go check out “SCP-682 - Ways SCP Foundation
Tried to Kill Hard To Destroy Reptile” and
“SCP-6415 - Tragedy of the Reptile Man”
for more fascinating reptilian anomalies!